ces campagnes électorales ressemblent un
peu à une tournée des Rolling Stones
Pékin Melbourne Tokyo ou encore Moscou
mon invité représente une partie des
Français établis à l'étranger elle est
députée de la plus grande des 577
[Musique]
circonscriptions
bonjour an jeuneté bonjour quand vous
étiez petite vous avez une discussion
avec votre père sur le sens de la vie et
la réponse qui vous a fait ce jour-là
vous a profondément marqué qu'est-ce
qu'il vous a dit il m'a dit je ne sais
pas et après il m'a dit je pense qu'on
est comme un grand mur de briqu et
chacun d'entre nous est une brique et tu
vois une brique ça soutient les autres
cell qui pourrait être un peu faible et
puis si toi un jour tu as un coup de mou
les autres te soutiendront donc essaie
d'être une bonne brique donc ça c'est
c'est une belle image si l'on peut dire
ah ça m'a porté constamment depuis et je
l'ai j'espère l'avoir transmis à mes
enfants et alors si on regarde votre
parcours de vie euh bah vous avez pas
été une mais plusieurs briques différent
dans votre vie vous avez été pédiatre
journaliste santé consultante en gestion
de crise sanitair blogueuse également
vous avez un peu la bougeotte vous avez
besoin de changer de de de vie de métier
régulièrement alors quand j'ai fait le
tour d'un sujet j'aime bien pouvoir en
changer quand les l'opportunité se
présente oui j'aime bien faire le tour
et puis savoir qu'à chaque fois je peux
être utile et quand à un moment je
bloque en me disant bon Benon je pense
que je suis arrivé au bout de ce que je
pouvais apporter pourquoi pas changer si
l'occasion se présente alors jeune
pédiatre vous avez d'abord travaillé
dans un Service de Protection Maternelle
Infantile de PMI vous avez ensuite
travaillé dans un centre de la
Croix-Rouge notamment au côté de de
toxicomane plus tard vous avez suivi
votre mari à à Singapour et là vous avez
aidé des travailleurs migrants
maltraités par leurs employeurs sans
faire de de politique en fait vous avez
toujours eu des des engagements assez
forts c'est quelque chose d'important
pour vous ça ah oui je reviens à l'image
de la Brig dans le mur comme le disait
mon père j'ai besoin d'être utile aux
autres j'aurais eu beaucoup de mal
d'ailleurs j'envisagais au départ de
j'ai fait une préparation aux écoles
d'ingénieur pour devenir ingénieur et
quand j'ai compris qu'ingénieur c'était
dans un bureau j'ai tourné le dost à ça
j'ai dit non c'est vraiment pas pour moi
j'avais besoin de me sentir directement
utile aux autres d'être sur le terrain
d'être auprès de ceux en me disant
depuis toute petite j'ai eu de la chance
depuis tout petite je me dis mais je
suis dans un pays incroyable dans une
famille incroyable dans un qutier
formidable pourquoi moi j'ai cette
chance et pas tout le monde ça ça me
travaille depuis longtemps donc j'avais
envie de rendre ce qu'on m'a donné
depuis toujours mais mais alors jamais
d'engagement politique avant 2017 ça
vous a jamais attiré très intéressé par
la politique en elle-même par le
fonctionnement de la société mais je
trouvais pas d'offre politique qui
engeloe tout ce à quoi j'aspirais il y
avait toujours un truc qui clochait qui
ne me convenait pas et donc je me suis
jamais engagé politiquement avant et en
2017 vous vous apprêtiez à devenir une
autre brique encore si l'on peut dire
vous étiez à Paris et là vous suiviez
une formation pour devenir médecin
urgentiste oui et et c'est là que la
politique est entrée dans votre vie avec
Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce ouais qui fait
que là vousêes dit c'est le moment j'y
vais alors toujours dans ce souci
d'aider les aut d'abord en 2002 Le Pen
au 2ème tour ça ça me frappe énormément
ensuite je vais à Singapour donc loin de
la France donc là encore j'ai un plus
grand impétence pour ce qui se passe en
France sur le plan politique
l'impression d'être vraiment inutile
pour le coup et puis là-dessus je
comprends dans les sondages que le pine
monte et là je me dis c'est pas possible
je pourrais pas regarder mes enfants
dans les yeux sans leur avoir dit
j'aurais essayé quelque chose et donc je
me suis dit il faut que je m'engage et
là à ce momentlà il y a l'offre Emmanuel
Macron qui repr présenter à la fois
l'humanisme ce souci de d'être au plus
proche de ceux qui ont des difficultés
c'est ce qui qui m'engageai depuis
longtemps et l'autre côté pas être non
plus dans un état coercitif parce que
j'avais pas mal voyagé dans les ex pays
de l'Est j'avais des souviens du bloc
soviétique he moi je suis né à l'époque
du mur de du mur la guerre froide et et
donc j'avais envie de je voulais pas de
ça et et donc j'ai trouvé là une offre
politique qui correspondait bien à moi
et donc le mouvement en marche vous a
investi dans la 11e circonscription des
Français de l'étranger je le disais
c'est la plus vaste de toutes les
circonscription elle compte 49 pays à
cheval sur trois continents 11 fuseaux
horaires comment est-ce qu'on fait on la
voit là sur ces images ça représente
vraiment une zone très importante
comment est-ce qu'on comment est-ce
qu'on fait campagne sur un territoire
aussi vaste alors nous avons la chance
nous à l'étranger déjà d'avoir le
fichier Email de tous nos électeurs donc
moi j'ai une base de données de 80000
emails déjà je pars sur une bonne base
ensuite j'utilise beaucoup les outils
numériques qui marche très bien moi j'ai
eu la surprise de voir des gens qui me
connaissaient alors je les avais jamais
rencontré me connaissaent à travers mes
communications comme quoi numérique ça
fonctionne et puis ensuite je me déplace
un peu pas partout je ne pourrais pas
visiter les 40 sur les 49 dans lesquels
on a des communautés françaises je
progresse petit à petit je me déplace
toujours quand il y a une vraie raison
d'y aller pour faire attention quand
même aux dépenses que ça engage à la
fatigue que ça génère à l'intérêt que ça
peut avoir pour nos communautés j'essaie
d'être utile encore une fois être utile
le plus utile possible ça c'est depuis
que vous êtes élu mais en campagne vous
avez quand même fait beaucoup de VoyaG
moi j'ai retrouvé vos affiches de
campagne de meeting de 2017 je le disais
au début de l'émission on dirait une
tournée des des Rolling Stones melbour
Shangai Tokyo Hong Kong dai Kyoto je pe
pas penser au parallèle c'est c'est tout
à fait ça mais il faut un sacré budget
avion notamment transport comment
comment vous financez ça c'estou alors B
d'abord je partais de Singapour donc
déjà et puis on est en Asie il y a des
vols low cost hein ça ça coûte moins
cher c'est pas des distances énormes le
budget est important mais il est pas
considérable et moi j'ai jamais dépensé
la totalité ni du Budet vous AZ un
budget spécial pour les campagnes à
l'étranger j'ai un budget pour les
campagnes à l'étranger qui est différent
de mes collègues en métropole mais il
est je ne l'ai jamais dépensé en
totalité loin de là ni pour la campagne
ni pour ma mission de parlementaire
après non non vous êtes donc depuis 2017
l'une des 11 députés des des Français
installés hors de France la taille de
votre circonscription fait que vous avez
dû trouver une façon original d'assurer
vos permanences parlementaires on va
voir ça en
image bonjour à tous je vais attendre
les premières connexion pour pouvoir
lancer notre échange puisque nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans la permanence la
permanence virtuelle que je vous propose
tous les mois et qui me permet de vous
présenter mon travail de parlementaire
et d'échanger avec vous et de répondre à
vos questions je vois déjà quelques
questions qui sont tombées dans le chat
donc la plupart des échanges que vous
avez avec vos administrés vos électeurs
je sais pas comment on les appelle c'est
comme ça soit par facebook live soit en
zoom quand c'est en en plus petit groupe
est-ce que c'est pas un peu frustrant
pour vous et peut-être pour eux alors
d'abord nousmême qui sommes à l'étranger
nous avons hababitude de ces outils là
avec nos familles avec nos amis avec nos
proches donc on a tous l'habitude
d'utiliser un écran de se voir par écran
interposé donc ça fait pas une grosse
différence par rapport à je dira presque
un notre quotidien j'ai pas le choix
j'ai pas le choix je peux pas faire
autrement mais ça m'embêche pas sur des
situations de crise et des situations
d'urgence de proposer un zoom et parfois
la veille pour le lendemain je comprends
que dans une communauté là il y a un
problème qui est Crist hop je propose un
zoom et le lendemain et là du coup on
échange quand même plus directement plus
facilement donc ça aide franchement
merci aux outils numériques donc vous
votre point d'attache he je le disais
c'est Singapour comment est-ce que vous
répartissez votre temps entre le Palais
Bourbon quand il faut aller voter les
lois Singapour et le reste de votre
circonscription alors le plus gros du
travail d'un parlementaire quel qu'il
soit c'est le Palais Bourbon et mes
collègues sont là généralement le mardi
le mercredi le jeudi au minimum souvent
même dès le lundi après-midi et parfois
le vendredi quand on siège jusqu'au
vendredi le gros du travail il est ici
même quand un administré nous sollicite
pour un problème qu'il a avec une
administration ministère de l'Intérieur
la CQ que sais-je les questions qu'on va
poser les responsables de ces entités
ils sont bien à Paris ils sont pas en
province ou ils sont pas à l'étranger
donc il faut absolument qu'on soit
présent moi contrairement à eux je peux
pas prendre un RER un TGV pour rentrer
le weekend donc j'y vais pendant
maintenant les séances de suspension des
travaux de l'Assemblée au précédent
mandat je pouvais y aller toutes les 4 5
semaines maintenant j'ai été obligé de
changer mon rythme avec la majorité
relative que nous voilà donc je suis
obligée d'y aller donc j'y vais la
semaine de suspension qu'on a en
novembre octobre novembre euh les TR
semaines de de Noël les la semaine de
février les de semaines d'avril ou dans
l'utre sens et puis je moctroit un petit
faveur c'est que au moment de la session
extraordinaire nous avons droit de
donner une délégation de vote donc je
voyage beaucoup en juillet et en
septembre en aû beauou vous pouvez pas
déléguer votre vote le reste du temps
c'est pas possible il y a pas de règles
dérogatoire pour extraordinaire session
extraordinaire de l'Assemblée donc du
coup ça limite pas mal le temps de
déplacement mais franchement cette année
avec ces contraintes là et ben
finalement j'ai fait autant de pays que
certaines années dans le précédent
mandat hors covid et alors le covid
justement comment est-ce que vous avez
géré vos allers-retours entre alors
Singapour pendant cette PE et bien le
hasard faisait enfin le hasard
l'organisation de mon travail faisait
que la moment de suspension des travaux
du mois de mars 2020 qui était la
période des élections municipales je me
trouvais en France et quand j'ai compris
que l'espace aérien allait fermé j'ai
même appelé en urgence mon épou pour lui
dire écoute là il te reste à mon avis 48
he maximum pour rentrer sinon après on
pourra plus se revoir et il a bien fait
de rentrer sinon on se serait pas vu
pendant 2 ans et donc vous êtes resté je
suis resté en France pendant 2 ans
puisque mon mon pays Singapour refusait
même moi avec un titre de séjour
permanent que je rent à Singapour
j'avais même pas le droit de rentrer il
y a même des pays qui ont interdit à
leurs propres ressortissant moi je
pouvais pas rentrer quand on se promène
sur vos réseaux sociaux on vous voit en
photo avec des ambassadeurs notamment
l'ambassadeur de Chine en France
l'ambassadeur d'Indonésie ou avec des
officiels dans les pays où vous déplacés
qui font partie de votre circonscription
comme le Parlement de la de la Corée du
Sud par
exemple vous êtes un peu député
diplomate on peut dire il y a une part
de diplomatie alors il y a une part de
diplomatie qui était aussiilié sur le
précédent mon au fait que j'étais membre
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et du coup dans ce cadre là oui je je
jouais pleinement mon rôle de diplomate
parlementaire de diplomatie
parlementaire savez un parlementaire
peut dire des choses que parfois nos
diplomates ne peuvent pas dire donc
c'est très utile et puis dans chacun des
pays j'ai à cœur de présenter nos
communautés aux responsables sur place
le dire voilà sachez que là vous avez
une communauté de 3000 français 10000
français 5000 français parfois ils se
rendent pas toujours compte les
difficultés auquel ils peuv être
confronté aussment les difficultés mais
la à tout moi je vends la France très
positivement en disant voilà vous avez
des entreprises qui font C qui
it vous avez un cholatier qui est
Françis vous avez un March de vin qui
est français j'aime bien vendre notre
pays à mes interlocuteurs sur place et
alors parfois vous donnerz l'impression
d'aller même au-delà de la diplomatie
c'était le cas notamment en 2021 quand
l'Australie a annulé le fameux contrat
géant où il s'agissait de construire 12
sous-marins pour 50 milliards de dollars
à l'époque vous avez fait une confidence
que je trouve surprenante on va on
vaevoir ça en image j'ai rencontré un
député de la majorité de Scott Morrison
Premier ministre actuel qui m'a dit j'en
veux pas de votre contrat il est
beaucoup trop cher je ferai tout ce que
je peux pour le déchirer il est pas
possible et vraiment il était très
agressif avec ce contrat alors j'étais
tellement stupéfaite que je m'en suis
ouverte aux autorités françaises et on
m'a dit oui oui oui oui on sait on sait
ça donne l'impression que là vous êtes
même plus diplomate c'est presque du
renseignement que vous faites je crois
que vous avez accès à des informations
comme ça qui sont pas encore oui mais
pas seulement moi je dirais que même
tous les Français qui sont installés à
l'étranger que j'ai à cœur de défendre
par les contacts que nous avons avec les
autorités locales avec des entreprises
avec des institutionnels peu importe on
a accès des informations dont la France
a besoin mais c'est vous travaillez en
comment dire en coordination avec le qu
d'oré sur certains sujets vous toujours
toujours he toujours c'est très
important important de se coordonner
s'assurer que j'ai les bons messages
qu'inversement eux peuvent me m'orienter
en disant là actuellement c'est sur ce
sujet là qu'on voudrait plutôt avancer
et inversement chaque fois que j'ai une
information que je joue pertinente je la
leur raorte absolument l'Ukraine fait
partie de de votre circonscription vous
avez d'ailleurs rencontré volodimir
zelensk à Kief puisque vous avez
accompagné la présidente de l'Assemblée
y elbron piivet dans dans son voyage sur
place euh est-ce que vous avez pu vous
rendre utile sous une forme ou une autre
quand la guerre s'est déclarée là-bas
j'ai eu beaucoup de contact avec les
Français sur place qui étaient dans dans
un questionnement important notamment
sur la position française sur ce qu'on
allait faire sur le soutien au moment du
rendez-vous avec volodimir zelanski le
le sujet que j'ai voulu lui lui poser et
sur lequel je continue à travailler j'ai
voulu l'alerter sur le risque que les
opinions publiques nous lâchent à un
moment ou un autre et donc notre not re
travail est à lui et à nous citoyens et
parlementaires c'est d'animer cette
opinion publique et dire voilà
n'oublions jamais l'Ukraine ne la
laissons jamais tomber donc là j'espère
être utile en faisant vivre l'Ukraine le
sujet ukrainien pour que jamais les
opinions publiques ne nous lâchent on va
passer à notre quiz à présent je vous
explique le principe c'est pas très
compliqué je vais commencer une phrase
et ça va ça va être à vous de de la
compléter on commence vu de Singapour
les débats dans l'hémicycle sont parfois
particulièrement animés et irrespectueux
tout à fait à l'oposé pas du tout comme
ça du tout en Asie mes collègues au
Palais Bourbon pensent souvent que Al
s'agiss son s'agissant de moi de vous et
et du fait d'être député de alors de
l'étranger on curieux interrogatif mais
euh je pense que je suis souvent vu
comme une députée souriante et soucieuse
du consensus enfin la prochaine brique
dans ma vie sera après celle de député
oh alors comme j'ai encore 4 ans de
mandat euh à 2 ans je ne sais déjà pas
ce que je vais faire mais en tout cas
les envies de faire plein de choses
toujours d'être utile au pays oui merci
beaucoup Anne je d'être venu dans la
politique et
[Musique]
moi